Hello everybody, I have an announcement to make.
We have a new channel. Yes, a new channel
It is named 'this' and you guys kind of chose the name by submitting it a billion times on Instagram. It's a new channel for
Team videos like directors commentaries, behind the scenes stuff like that. Be sure to go subscribe to it and check it out after this
There's a video I made up there right now. For now
Enjoy this episode of "Odd Man Out". We shot this in February. So there is
some talk about people who have since left the
Presidential race but that's fine, still a good video. I guess I'll see you over at the other channel
What do you think? Gotta go. I'll see you later. Bye. Bye
Most of us have a set idea on what a Democrat looks like and believe that they belong to a certain demographic
Do you have similar biases as well?
Health care for all. If that's socialism, sign me up.
Let's see with this episode of "Odd Man Out", how easy it is for you to find the secret Republican.
We brought together seven Democrats.
I'm a Democrat. I'm a Democrat. I am a Democrat. I'm a Democrat. I am a Democrat
I'm a Democrat. I'm a Democrat.
One is a liar. If the group discovers who the liar is, they'll split a cash prize.
If the liar survives, they win the entire prize. Who is the odd man out?
When did like everybody become a Democrat?
Honestly, when I was at school. I grew up in a really small town in Nebraska, it was very white, we had Fox News on TV all the time...
You are not helping your case bro.
I know, I know but- You are not helping, I know my vote
Brandon kinda is coming after me, just saying stuff like that's a bad move for bringing up like that
I'm from Nebraska and that I grew up with in a conservative family
So I thought maybe you know him coming off that strongly that he could have been the mole
Where'd you go to school? Oklahoma State University, which does not help my case at all either but...
I come from a conservative family. I went to college. I was like-  Where did you go to college? USC
(Brandon) Democratic family over here.
Think I was targeting Nick a little bit. USC is known for being a more private conservative school
First of all, I'm Black
I think the Democratic Party aligns with interests of Black people. Republican Party really doesn't offer anything
Medicare is a big thing for me. My father passed away right before I was born, didn't have health insurance
And so when he got sick and got cancer, it just happened so late. I don't want that happen to anybody else's parents
The most important issue for me is the environment. I think Trump pulling out of the Paris agreement was
Horrible, I think the US should lead this global initiative towards renewable energy
You are making me cry, I'm trying to get it together right now.
If the election was today, who would you vote for?
Andrew Yang
Why?
I think his like the freedom divident of a thousand  dollars a month helps like the far majority of people in America...
I don't mean to interrupt, but also I don't feel like Andrew Yang really
Emphasizes the points that you first brought up about health care and I think like Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders...
Yes, he is for Medicare for all though.
Okay true, but like I feel like other politicians especially who would like- Would be more, yeah I agree.
I'm planning to vote for Elizabeth Warren. What are your views on abortion?
Pro-choice, easy
Were you lying?
Blake was inconsistent with what policies are really most important to him.
I think a really important question is what values really make you a Democrat? Why don't you start out with your own question?
Sure. I am Iranian American
Sorry, I didn't get that.
I'm Iranian American.
Okay, yeah your parents are immigrants.
Yeah, my parents are immigrants
When Sarah started asking questions, Sai kind of cut her off and I don't know that seemed kind of like a very aggressive way to come at it
Woman's rights are really important to me as well as like
Environmental rights. I'm a huge Bernie Sanders supporter
What ways do you support the women's rights movement? Well like abortion, Planned Parenthood
I'm half black half Mexican and my mom was actually
brought here as a baby from TJ and then my dad's obviously Black and
Kinda like you said, black people are Democrats.
I don't like people telling me what to do so like a hundred and fifty percent pro-choice.
I think Jazlyn was protected by Brandon
Which is completely valid because people of color should protect people of color
but I just felt like I didn't want to come in and be a little bit of a bully and
Try to get to the root of the question
But I would say like I'm a baby Democrat cuz I grew up, I grew up Christian. My main thing is
Abortion, healthcare. Again, baby Democrat. I like just got into it, so-
Welcome. Thank you
If you're real, welcome.
Both my parents are immigrants my mom was born in Grenada. My dad was born in Paris, France
And then I'm currently in school. I'm a political science major, pre-law concentration.
Then minors in ethnic studies- don't think a Republican would take that, first of all.
Anthropology and geography. You didn't laugh Nick, you didn't laugh.
I'm smiling, I love your story.
I was a theater major you guys, how many Republicans are theater majors?
I would say my biggest values is I'm a staunch feminist
like I'm absolutely pro-choice and I believe in women's autonomy over their bodies.
Obviously women's rights is huge to me. There needs to be autonomy
Gun control also extremely important.
The big thing that made me a Democrat was
Knowing in a high school that I was gay
And I was raised in the military, in the era of Don't Ask Don't Tell, carried a lot of shame
How old are you real quick?
30.
Oh dang, thought you were in your twentys.
Oh yeah you look so young.
Thank you, thank you.
I think we all were just really open with each other
All the other women in the box had very like concrete examples to back up why they were a
Feminist and why they were pro-choice. It really sucked that I had to like vote Sarah out
But in my head her answer was a little less supported
I'm gonna start off somewhere really weird, but it's just based of a study I read if
You guys were to see a severed hand floating in a glass bottle. How disgusted would you be?
A severed hand in a glass bottle?
Such an intense question. I would
How disgusted would you be?
I would probably be pretty disgusted. I'm gonna say.
I would probably throw up, blood really freaks me out
Okay.
Is it bloody and stuff?
However your mind goes with it. How disgusted?
I can't even imagine it, so like I'm not gonna say super disgusting but obviously wouldn't just have it on my mantel piece
My gut reaction isn't gross it's more like comical and confused but yeah, I would like to know more information
Okay, wait why? Yeah, what's the study?
Okay, essentially a study in 2014
Said that like based on like brains of Democrats versus Republicans
Republicans are more likely to have a good gut
Reaction of something being a more disgusting
At the same time though- It is based on thought processing.
That's interesting, cuz you two, like you are the baby Democrat and you were, at least your family was conservative
Both Nick and Jaz were really disgusted and that's why like both of them were kind of on my list
I thought Sais question was really interesting
And what's so funny is I answered
differently than what I was thinking in my head because I was thinking that if I saw a jar with a hand I
Would be like, oh there's a jar
It wouldn't really bother me
But I answered that it would because I thought that it would be the answer they were looking for and it turns out that it
Totally was wrong to do that, ooops.
For your top like two candidates. What are the issues that like you most resonate with their platform?
I'm a big Warren person because I love the way she's run her campaign that it seems so...
For the most part, definitely not the Native American thing.
Exactly,  that is oh my gosh
But she seems like she's really out to meet people personally
And she spends hours waiting to take selfies and she calls people personally and she's only taking money from regular
Citizens not big huge donors and I appreciate that so much.
I felt like Nick didn't come across as
Passionate his answers just seemed a little
Premeditated and I felt they were just kind of run off without emotion behind them
I really like Warren but I leaned a little bit more toward Sanders because I was a sociology major and so
Sociology? No, I but I like it.
Okay, I'm a people person and in order for
Everybody to succeed. We all need to build each other up not tear each other down and so Bernie, he's very...
What policies of Bernie?
His racial justice is like a big thing for me, immigration, and then obviously universal health care
And I'm not gonna lie. A lot of the stuff I get is from like Black Twitters, so
Which is totally a valid source though
I had a target on my back that entire game. I think age might have been a factor
I think that the the four that were left seemed to really be
connecting as younger people
What?! It's you isn't it? Oh my god, I know now
I named my dog after Bernie Sanders.
I knew it!
Oh my gosh I knew it. I voted you first!  You're lucky you're Black!
I was the most suspicious of the actual mole. I didn't believe Jazlyn at all when she said she's a baby Democrat
That's an excuse for being okay. I'm Republican. I'm coming out this show and I'm going to pretend to be a Democrat
So let me say that I'm a new one then that way people will go easier on me
When Brandon said that his first reasoning for being a Democrat was because he's Black, the way that I was thinking
Coming at it was he would never assume that another Black person
Would be a Republican let alone want to be very friendly with him and joke around
I had my suspicions, I was like
I wouldn't be surprised if she's the mole but in my head I was like I hope it's not Jazlyn visible
It comes down to identities as a Black person for better for worse. I think Black people should stick together.
Oh, it's just in here?
Oh shoot! I feel bad but like I gotta pay off my student loans
Sorry guys, but not really.
The stereotype of Republicans is we're not white.
We can be mixed-race we can be of someone that comes from an immigrant household, like I did. I'm very pro-wall.
Very Pro Trump. I do believe that immigrants have the right to vote but legal immigrants
No, I am NOT pro-choice. I am pro-life
I used to think that Democrats a lot of them don't really care about what's going on
Like politically they only care about what's on like media
I really like seeing that a lot of them had their reasoning for being a Democrat
Followed with their morals or followed with their beliefs
Most stereotypes about what political party you're in are not true
We have an idea in this country of what each
party is and you know what your interests are if you're a Democrat or a Republican or what you look like and it's
It's unfortunate because no matter who you are you could I guess fall into either category